[Music]
another industry in which I would say
the only other industry in which their
truck there is automation actually
touching people's lives today is
autonomous vehicles mmm-hmm
what the vision each is described of
using computer vision and using cheap
camera sensors that's there's a debate
on that of lidar versus computer vision
and sort of the Elon Musk famously said
that lidar is a crutch that really in
camera in the long term camera only is
the right solution which echoes some of
the ideas you're expressing of course
the domain in terms of its safety
criticality is different but what do you
think about that approach in the
autonomous vehicle space and in general
do you see a connection between the
incredible real-world challenges you
have to solve in the home with Roomba
and I saw a demonstration of some of
them corner cases literally and
autonomous vehicles so there's
absolutely a tremendous overlap between
both the problems you know a robot
vacuum and a Thomas vehicle are trying
to solve and the tools and the types of
sensors that are being applied in the
pursuit of the solutions in my world my
environment is actually much harder than
the environment and automobiles we don't
have roads we have t-shirts we have
steps we have a near infinite number of
patterns and colors and surface textures
on the floor especially from a visual
perspective so yeah well looks it's
really tough is an infinitely variable
on the other hand safety is way easier
on the inside my robots they're not very
heavy they're not very fast if they bump
into your foot you think it's funny
and you know and and autonomous vehicles
kind of have the inverse problem and so
that for me saying vision is the future
I can say that without reservation for
autonomous vehicles I think I believe
what you nan saying about the future is
ultimately going to be vision maybe if
we put a cheap lighter on there and as a
backup sensor it might not be the worst
idea in the world so the something so
much higher take so much higher that's
much more careful thinking through how
far away that feature is right right and
but I think that the primary
environmental understanding sensor is
going to be a visual system
you